SOPHIA HU: Hello, everyone.
I'm Sophia Hu, a data management
specialist based in Tokyo.
Today I'm going to talk
about how Cloud Spanner helps
gaming companies organize their
gaming application and better
players' experience.
ML can help you predict many
things today and it's amazing.
But one thing it cannot predict
is a successful video game.
So what are we
trying to solve here
with our database solutions?
Unpredictability.
Compute is very easy to scale.
You need more resource,
you add more server.
When a game gets
a lot of players,
database is usually
the bottleneck.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
DB like MySQL,
are not designed to
scale horizontally.
How did gaming companies solve
the database scaling problem?
Well, by using a
technical called sharding.
The first one shards
data by player's name.
The more you [INAUDIBLE]
the DB, the more
players your game will handle.
Second one is realm sharding.
This is typical in
MMORPG, where you
create new, parallel
worlds when you
need to handle more players.
If a single database server
can handle 10,000 players,
then they have to manage
100 servers for each million
players.
Last one is platform
sharding, where
you will separate players'
population by platform.
What if you could simply
scale your game backend?
That's where Cloud
Spanner comes in.
Cloud Spanner is the
first enterprise-grade,
globally-distributed, and
strongly-consistent database
service built for the
cloud specifically
to combine the benefit of
relational database structure
with non-relational
horizontal scale.
What are the key benefits of
using Cloud Spanner for gaming
application?
Manually sharding makes
it difficult to maintain
consistency and
transactions across shards.
Cloud Spanner gives
you relational data
and horizontal scaling.
It optimizes performance by
automatically sharding the data
based on the load
and [? data ?] sites.
Customers who are using
RDBMS want more power
and are considering a
scalable [INAUDIBLE] database.
Spanner allows them to
keep their relational data
and can be scaled.
Cloud Spanner has no planned
downtime for maintenance,
with fully automatic data
replication and server
redundancy.
And it delivers up to
five 9s of availability
in multi-region instances.
Also, Cloud Spanner users
can make a schema change
while serving traffic
with zero downtime.
With Spanner in a
multi-region configuration,
any update is automatically
replicated across regions
so that you don't have to
add extra logic for that
in your application.
Let's take a look
at some examples
of companies using Spanner.
Niantic learned about
how Google Cloud
can help gaming
companies ensure they
have enough scale for a
surprise hit with "Pokemon Go."
"Pokemon Go" wildly exceeded
the team's capacity estimates
and they used Google Cloud
data store to scale to over 50
times their prediction
worst case scenario.
After a few years,
Niantic migrated
from [INAUDIBLE]
to Spanner, which
reduces their operational
cost and improved latency.
Another example is "Dragon Ball
Legends" from Bandai Namco.
With Cloud Spanner
as a backend DB,
BNE focused on developing
an amazing game instead
of spending time on database
capacity planning and scaling.
By using a fully managed
scalable database,
they drastically
reduced the risk
related to human errors as
well as operational overhead.
Let's take a quick deep
dive into a Spanner
and some of the benefits
of cloud native.
The Google network offers
better reliability,
speed, and security
performance, as
compared with
non-deterministic performance
of the public internet
or other cloud networks.
Spanner's capabilities
are augmented
by our global,
private fiber optic
network that stitches
together all of our services
and allows us to provide
low latency backend.
Spanner has two type of
instances, regional or
multi-region instance.
The diagram represents a
two-node regional instance.
For each node,
Cloud Spanner will
create three synchronous
replicas across zones.
Each zone in the region contains
a few replica of the database.
With multi-region
configuration, Cloud Spanner
will create up to nine
replicas for each node.
These additional
replicas enable you
to read data with low latency
from multiple locations close
to or within the regions
in the configuration.
Here I'd like to highlight
the new multi-region instance
configuration in Asia called
Asia1 with Tokyo, Osaka,
and Seoul region.
It's often mentioned
that TrueTime
is essential to make Spanner
work as well as it does.
So what is it, and
how does it help?
TrueTime is a way to
synchronize clocks
in all machines across
multiple data centers.
The system uses a combination
of GPS and automatic clocks
to give an accurate
source of time
for all Google's application.
Cloud Spanner assign a
timestamp to every read
and write transaction.
Different nodes
can make decisions
about the order of transaction
operation made from other nodes
by simply comparing
these timestamps.
It enables applications
to generate monotonically
in creating timestamps, which
allow the system to behave
as if all transactions
were executed sequentially,
even though Cloud Spanner
actually runs them
across multiple servers
in multiple data
centers for higher
performance and availability.
It's a combination of Google's
fast, redundant global network
and TrueTime makes Google Cloud
Spanner external [INAUDIBLE]
possible.
So how do we spread the
data to Spanner nodes?
Each table in the
database is broken down
into several what we
call splits, used range
of the primary keys.
All the data in a split is
physically stored together
in a replica.
And Cloud Spanner servers
serve each replica an out
of independent failure zone.
For example, this table is
separated into a three splits
using range of the keys.
In reality, the number of
splits can vary according
to the amount of the data.
And the splits are rebalanced
dynamically depending
on the amount of data and load.
So for the three node
instances we saw previously,
it could be managed
like this, going back
to our original scenario,
with each node handling
three of the splits.
But remember that the
table and the nodes
are replicated
across three zones.
How does that work?
Look across the three zones.
Each split is replicated
in all three zones.
Use Paxos consensus
protocols, one of the zones
is determined to be a leader.
The leader is
responsible for managing
write transactions
for that split,
while the other replicas
can be used for reads.
Every write operation must
pass a majority quorum vote.
For different splits,
different zones
can become leaders, thus
distributing the leadership
roles among all of the
Cloud Spanner compute nodes.
It's using the distributed
mechanism of splits, leaders,
and replicas that
Cloud Spanner gains
both its high availability
and scalability.
Let's talk about what
scalability looks
like in practice.
By increasing the number
of nodes, you add capacity.
A node can handle around 2,000
writes per second and 10,000
reads per second.
Imagine we're approaching
launch date for our game.
And based upon the throughput
capability of a Spanner node,
they've determined that we
need a three-node cluster
for a total potential
threshold of 6,000
writes per second and
30,000 reads per second.
Based upon our best
estimates, they've
determined that three
nodes of Spanner
should be sufficient for
anticipated launch date load.
You can configure cost
performance capacity
with the number of nodes.
Shortly after
launch, the game goes
viral and traffic surges,
pushing the Spanner instance
passed performance thresholds.
We can easily go in and
add an additional node
to our instance.
Once a node has been
added to the instance,
the nodes add their
pointers to the splits,
[? node ?] is moved.
Now with the additional node, we
have a new performance ceiling
of 40,000 reads per second
and 8,000 write per second,
and performance
begins to stabilize.
Crisis averted, and with
a minimum amount of fuss.
No frantic re-architecting,
re-sharding,
re-platforming of the data.
Behind the scene, this
is a Spanner dynamically
re-sharding the data.
After some time, performance
returns to pre-surge levels
and we find ourself with
significant additional
capacity.
To help save cost, we decided
to add it to the instance
and remove the additional
node that had been added.
So far, I have described
some key concept
and advantages of Spanner
for gaming customers.
I hope I could give you a quick
overview regarding how Spanner
can help gaming applications
with strong consistency,
dynamic scale, global
data distribution,
and live operation.
Cloud Spanner has been
tremendously adopted
in gaming industry and
I'm so excited to have
one of our very cool
customers, Colopl,
here today to share their
story with Cloud Spanner.
TAKAYASU OYAMA:
Thank you, Sophia.
Hi, my name is Taka and
I'm a software engineer
for a Japanese game
company called Colopl.
I will take over from
here and briefly talk
about how we use Cloud
Spanner in our game
"Dragon Quest Walk."
Before I begin, please allow
me to do a brief introduction
about the game.
"Dragon Quest Walk" is part of
a long-running "Dragon Quest"
series owned by a company
called Square Enix.
And here are some
screenshots of what
the actual game looks like.
This is a role-playing game
where you walk around and fight
virtual monsters in real
world locations using GPS
and AR on your mobile devices.
Here are some numbers to give
you an insight of how much data
we process every day.
So the game was released in
September of 2019 in Japan,
and it has been downloaded
over 5 million times just
in the first week.
Currently we have millions
of monthly active users,
which are handled by
over 10,000 pods on GKE.
And through these
pods, we process
thousands of queries per second
across hundreds of Spanner
nodes every day.
Here's the agenda
for what I'm going
to be talking about today.
First, I will start by talking
about why we chose Spanner.
Then I will talk about
how we integrated Spanner
into our development.
After that, I will
provide some tips
on how to use Spanner
in real life scenarios.
So now I'll talk about why
we Spanner for this game.
There are three reasons.
Scalability, cost,
and stability.
Starting with the first one
on the list, scalability.
We used to use MySQL to
handle all user data.
And we scaled it by splitting
data into horizontal shards.
This worked well for a while,
but when the numbers of shards
grew to double
digits, we started
to notice some problems
with this approach
whenever we wanted to scale.
Scaling in and out
took days to prepare,
and we scaled every month.
So we would scale out whenever
we released a new feature
to handle the high traffic.
And then we would
scale in to save costs
once the traffic eased.
By switching to Spanner, we were
able to do this with one click
and scaling would complete
within a few minutes.
The second reason is cost.
Like I mentioned in
the previous slide,
we used to spend
days scaling MySQL.
But switching to Spanner
enabled us to reduce the time
it takes from days
to minutes, and that
reduced the cost of
operation quite a bit.
Another place we save costs
is from code maintenance.
Sharding made the code
complex and difficult
to maintain because the
code had to accommodate
for things like distributed
transactions and replication
delays.
These things made it costly
to add features and fix bugs.
But using Spanner allowed
us to simplify the code
so adding features and fixing
bugs can be done a lot cheaper.
The third reason we chose
Spanner was for stability.
As mentioned by Sophia, Spanner
has at least four 9 SLA,
which is phenomenal.
When we self-managed
MySQL servers, which
amounted to hundreds,
a small number of them
used to crash randomly
at a constant rate.
And having these crashes
used to cause a lot of grief.
After switching to
Spanner, we haven't had
any of these types of crashes.
We've been running this
game for 10 months now,
and we haven't had
any major downtimes.
Now, I would like to talk
about how we integrated Spanner
into the game's development.
Here's the architecture overview
of how it looked like before we
started using Spanner.
As you can see, MySQL was used
to store all persistent data
we used in the game.
And here's the architecture
overview after the integration.
As you can see,
Spanner replaced MySQL
for storing persistent data.
You might have noticed
that MySQL's still
used for shared data.
I'll be explaining that
later in the presentation.
So now I'll explain how we
actually did the integration,
starting with some background.
When we first decided
to integrate Spanner
into the game, we
knew it was going
to be a challenge, since
the game was already
in development using MySQL.
So we did some
preparations to make
sure this transition would
be smooth and painless
as possible.
So here is the process we
took to integrate Spanner
into the model.
First, we started with
a small dedicated team
that ran some basic benchmarks
to check the performance.
Once that was good, we
created a dedicated driver
for the PHP framework we
were using called Laravel.
Doing so allowed us to use
the framework's ORM, which
also made it possible
to use extensions
we built in other games.
So once the driver was
written, we tested the driver
by replacing MySQL driver
with a Spanner driver
on an existing game.
This method worked
well because you
got to see how it performed
in real life scenarios.
After that was done, we joined
the game development team
to educate them through
learning workshops.
So by doing these preparations,
the game development team
was able to fully integrate
Spanner in about two weeks.
Now, I'd like to give
you some tips for using
Spanner in real life scenarios.
The first item on the list
is handling bursts of access
to shared data.
So our game had some
small sets of data which
is shared across all users.
These are things
like item properties
and monster map coordinates.
Now, if we access
these data in Spanner,
we would get what's called a
hotspot in the database, which
caused latency to shoot up.
This happens because all the
I/O is happening on one slice
of data that cannot
be distributed,
as you can see in this slide.
This is troubling, but there
is a way to work around this.
The way to handle this
kind of data in Spanner
is to add a column
with a shard number
and insert copies of the data
with shard numbers assigned
to them.
Then what you can do is have
the app select one of the shards
at random and add
that to the query.
And that will
distribute the load.
This implementation works,
but unfortunately, we
did not use this
solution in the game,
because we figured it was
too difficult to implement
into the framework at the time.
So our actual solution to
this problem looks like this.
Yes, we decided to use a
self-managed MySQL instead,
since MySQL can replicate
and scale out easily
if all you have is that
small set of read-only data.
The next thing I would
like to talk about
is handling launch day traffic.
So as described earlier, when
there is high load on a split,
it adds more boundaries
to distribute the load.
This works well in
normal scenarios where
there is a gradual
growth on load,
but this was not
what we expected
to happen on launch day.
No, what we expected
to happen on launch day
was thousands of
users registering
in a span of a few seconds.
So we did a simulation
of launch day traffic
by ramping up game bots
that mimicked user behavior,
and this is how it turned out.
Immediately after we started
the test, the CPU usage shot up
and latency of the queries
increased to the point
where it was unplayable.
The reason this happened was
because Spanner could not
make the splits fast enough to
handle the huge amount of data
that was being inserted.
So we concluded that in
order to make Spanner handle
this massive traffic,
we needed to make
the splits before the launch.
So this is how we
resolved the issue.
We fed Spanner just enough
queries to allow the load base
split to trigger, and
increased the number of queries
gradually until there was enough
splits to handle the desired
PPS.
This was a tricky process,
because if we fed it too many,
the CPU would starve,
which slowed down
the splitting process.
But if we gave it
too little, there
wouldn't be enough load
to trigger the split.
So we had to monitor
the metrics constantly
to ensure that we fed Spanner
the right amount of queries.
Since this was a tedious task
that took hours to complete,
we made a warm-up app that
automated the whole process.
And here's an
illustration of what
the whole process looks like.
So in addition to what
I've just described,
there are two
things you should be
aware of when doing a warm-up.
So number one is do not drop
the tables after the warm-up.
In most cases, you would want
to delete dummy records that
were inserted
during the warm-up,
but don't do it by
dropping the tables,
because that will
also clear the splits.
You should delete
individual records instead,
since that will allow
the splits to remain.
So the second thing
you should know
is to warm up 24 hours
before the launch.
Spanner seems to merge the
splits if they aren't being
accessible over 48
hours, so make sure you
warm up your database 48
hours prior to launch.
So the last thing I want to
advise is how to scale in.
So in this game, we scaled
in and out fairly often
based on how much traffic
we're expecting for the day.
Scaling out a simple,
since all you have to do
is increase the number
of nodes in the UI
and wait a few minutes
for it to be deployed.
Scaling in, however,
is a bit more tricky.
When we scale in by
reducing the number of nodes
too aggressively, we
noticed that the latency
increase for some users.
These latencies ranged
from a few milliseconds up
to something like 30 seconds.
So we resolved this
issue by forcing Spanner
to time-out in three seconds and
return a retry response, which
asked the client to retry
after a few seconds.
In addition to that, we
now reduce the number
of nodes in small
intervals, since the latency
seems to be proportional to
the number of nodes we reduced.
We managed to minimize the delay
enough that no retries occurred
on the client by reducing the
number to one node per five
minutes.
So the takeaway
here is, don't try
to reduce the number
of nodes in one go,
but reduce them gradually
in small intervals.
That's all I have for you today.
Thank you for your time.
Handing it back to you, Sophia.
SOPHIA HU: Thank you,
Taka, for your great story.
For the next steps, we
have a few more sessions
about Spanner.
So if you have time,
please watch them as well.
Also, we have Demo and
Qwiklab about Spanner as well.
Please try them out.
OK, that's all
for today from us.
Thank you for watching.